the best businesses leaders will on a
semi-irregular basis it could you know
depending on the size of the business it
could be once a year you know but but
you go out to the field
or you call people up and say
how are you just checking in wanted to
see how you're doing
um or what do you tell me about I want
to learn about your career Ambitions
like you know how did you find yourself
in this profession like where do you
want to go like what are your Ambitions
do you with kids do you have a family
tell me something about you do you like
working here you know can you give me
some what what is something that we can
do better what's something that I'm not
seeing like and and some of it might be
you know sort of helpful and some of it
might not be helpful but the point is is
you'll get information that you
ordinarily wouldn't get
um and most important they've probably
never been asked before ever and so
simply showing up
um to listen or take them out for lunch
and and and and and and get get their
input about the business
um what they they're on the front line
so they actually have a lot of customer
information that you don't have
um and so talking to them about what
they're hearing what they're seeing that
what other business opportunities do you
think they think there are
um listening is a big thing Lynn
listening is active and listening is
very difficult you know you should be at
the end of the day of listening you
should be exhausted right because you're
not listening for words you're listening
for meaning and the goal of listening is
not to prove that you heard the goal of
listening is that they feel heard right
um and so you don't have to agree with
everything and you don't have to like
everything you have to take it in
you can ask clarifying questions but
remember they're going to take a risk to
tell you something and if you receive it
graciously they'll tell you more and
more and more and you'll develop a
relationship where honesty and truth
becomes the currency if you're defensive
or you attempt to correct or or dismiss
what they say they'll shut down and
they'll tell you what you want to hear
or tell you nothing because that's the
condition you created and so good
listening sounds like this can you tell
me other things in this business that
you think that we can do better
and it doesn't matter if they're right
or wrong it's their experience and you
don't have to agree we always say that
if you have an emotional response if it
makes you angry or upset it's probably
true if you feel nothing about what they
said then maybe they misunderstood but
you can still take it all in write it
down and say tell me more
go on
go on what else and that's basically
your entire job what else go on and
you'll walk away the list and you'll be
like I knew these things are ready these
things I didn't know these things it's
just a bit of a fast that's okay
everybody has that but you'll walk away
with some information but most
importantly they feel heard